you've got this construction of this
diagram this diagram is one of hundreds
of diagrams that prove this identity
we're going to end up with once we
finish the last question
we talk in algebra intrigue about
expressions equations and identities
just the other month - do you remember
what's the difference between an
equation and is yes it's good
okay identities are true for all values
of whatever pretty rules of index right
so for example just to come back to this
here in an equation and only true for
one value of x right but here is an
identity it's true for all values of X
then you can supply does that make sense
cool so what we're going to do is we're
going to come up with an identity for
what this is equal to you've been
working with trig functions for a little
while but what happens when you put not
one but two angles inside the angle the
argument up there so the target shape
okay now I don't worry too much about
all of this stuff here all it's doing is
just restating what's in the diagram all
of the well there's only one length
that's been given to you that one over
there so if you like you can picture
this on a gigantic unit circle if you
want to cook don't worry about that a
whole bunch of perpendicular lines now
cubed most of them I've already
indicated on the diagram here's what
you're actually being asked to do in
order to actually prove this identity
all the angles in this diagram you can
get that in terms of these two angles
down here the angles can be anything you
like 13:45 78 whatever what that's why I
give it a throwing voice because they
can take any value all angles in now we
can find in terms of those two and all
of the distances on
rooms you can find in terms of trig
functions of those angles let me try and
explain what I mean by way of example
this is take you that's the first we
have to find so first just have a look
at your diagram and tell me where PQ is
where is it beautiful added to your
words have a look over there it's
alright yep in here okay so I'm just
going to label it like that
now if that's the length I'm awesome
can you see and you may like to do this
yourself in front of a color bear this
our length PQ it exists inside this
right angle triangle do you see that you
see that one I highlighted there in blue
and you can see that my angle over there
in the bottom right hand corner okay
since it's a right angle triangle I can
use all of the stuff I know from right
angled triangle tree this I'm real
particular some rule required so have a
look this is what I'm asked up over here
and I know what this angle into corner
is so how long how could I work out the
length of that time with all the
information that I've got any
suggestions well thank you for turns in
for City Museum
have a look this is the side of Arthur
this is a side I know
so what piece of news mission policemen
are in beta yeah sine of beta down here
is going to be opposite the one I want
on hypotenuse do you agree so let me
here on the side you've got enough space
on that piece of paper to write this by
the way I would write here's a triangle
earth P cute by the way
I'm going to encourage you whenever
you're doing anything involving the
cycle control our area triangle or just
your regular trig ratios
please make the triangle you're talking
about oh yeah they haven't done daylight
savings so tell me in trouble you've got
a lot of triangles flying around so
please name the triangles you're talking
about so that as the Marquardt I can
know that you know what we talked about
the suggestion was using sine sine of
beta
it's going to be opposite on hypotenuse
opposite is P Q and the length of the
hypotenuse in this case it is 1 so
therefore if you just have a look at
that equation there I can say P Q is
equal to serbia that's it
so in fact I'm going to write over here
sighs Ben are you following okay so this
is why I mean by that length over there
is side B de okay have a look at the
next one Oh
q can you without my help have a look at
where OQ is and what information don't
go chatter just have a look what would
you write down to work out the length of
okay I'll give you 30 things don't
really like that yeah yeah so in I want
you to say one fantastic so you've got
this time this like a near sin triangle
but adjacent on hypotenuse that's
getting most useful right so being the
third ones just produce I can say that I
displayed here is now cause video do you
see what I'm doing
so I'm now constructing what all the
lengths in here in terms of the angles
and trig functions of those instance
okay this is a 2h where is that now my
this is a lot but I'm going to hold your
head so work out now if you can do the
rest he's a Q over here do you see it
okay now this is another right angle
triangle you know what this angle in the
corner is it alpha okay so what's the
name of the triangle that length a Q is
if you name it for me in triangle Oh a
cute right okay so which trig function
will I use it's the most trig ratio
rather than foolish useful see it's
going to be citing it because look
here's alpha and that goes all the way
on the opposite side so I can say sine
alpha now sine alpha will be opposite
over hypotenuse then
a queue on what yeah this side that I
just found out does that make sense but
one that does a triangle event I mean
this train does beyond so all you have
to do if you have a look over there on
the right hand side is to make a to the
subject I just have to multiply through
by convener which should give you this
I know it's bit of a mouthful but that's
what the trigonometry tells me does that
make sense so that was part one through
three can you do part four through six
same kind of ideas again set it out just
like I have up here the right-hand side
and if you think you have a non-starter
bpq certainly where is it where is it
simple it's right there at that top is
that the sharp angle over there okay
so vividly like there's a lot of lines
flying around one of the hardest things
about most geometry questions is sifting
out the unimportant information from the
important information that you can use
so here I want to help you see notice
how I've got all of these parallel and
perpendicular lines okay so for instance
see oh a this horizontal line the other
one okay
do you notice that it's parallel to our
cube that horizontal line sort of there
in the middle okay now if it's parallel
that means that this angle alpha down
here in the corner is also equal to
there is no actually there's a few
different alphas there that you can see
right um I want to get as close as I can
to this angle up here that you are
telling me I need right now on the top
so what's the most direct way I can buy
the Alpha this close to that angle in
that triangle yeah just like the little
we've got a name got a name you tell me
then oh are you see are you see do you
see that arc you see is also alpha
what's the reason by the way alternate
angles are parallel lines not going to
eat you to state that but just so you
can see what's going on right PC of the
radius in a minute
today see you back thank you got oil to
the angles that's good
now this is positive now I'm in this
triangle that's a start
he let alpha it's adjacent to this other
angle in here and together they are 90
degrees they're complementary so what
does that make the other angle 90 - am i
90 degrees minus alpha degrees but now
look look
have a look in triangle PQR now take you
on
do you see if that's 90 minus alpha over
there this is right angle so therefore
it's got to be alpha degrees to get me
angles of the triangle does that make
sense so now I can use that to work out
the rest of the pub I think if I recall
the next question is PR and that the
distance Trent finds me they are so this
is the length I'm after now I noticed
some angles in this triangle and I also
know another length so if I know that
this is alpha a period the corner what
is the ratio that connects the green
side which I want to find with the blue
side that I already know it's going to
be cause isn't it can you see that an
adjacent on hypotenuse look away the
right angle is yes so I'm going to say
is this one up here in triangle PQR as
Justin called alpha is equal to adjacent
at the one you need over hypotenuse
which is the one you know so far so good
all right so I can make PR the subjects
fairly easily that did it become by
multiplying through by Siberia so
therefore this is cos alpha sine BM you
came with that you see how I've got that
that green vertical length I can almost
there the final question is sorry five
sign off as the files just alpha plus
beta now where is alpha plus beta
it's your to that kind of rant and yeah
it's the red of the blue together right
so alpha plus beta is those two a or
sitting next to each other which is
exactly what you've got down here so I'm
just going to label that and she's my
last color now that guy there is alpha
plus you know yeah so the right angle
triangle that angle is in in order name
was it cool P Oh be right here and see
so that's the triangle I'm in so what is
sine of alpha plus beta in the triangle
what does it give you which leg is it
it's going to be a VP like VP sine of
alpha plus beta is opposite that's this
guy on hypotenuse which is one so all I
really need is VP but you can see what
VP is coaching right
you've got caught up to sine beta P R
and because it's a nicely done diagram
and you can see all these right angles
this sine alpha cos beta is the same
length over here does that make sense
so this whole length you're after BP is
this screen Plus this red you okay with
that so let's write that as a summary
rag and one purgatory here sine of alpha
cos beta
unlike many people say oh I'll just get
rid of the bracket that must be sine
alpha plus sine beat up well it's not
too hard to work out if you just crunch
some numbers like say put in phenomena
that you know like a xxx xxx sign what's
very plus so well it needs were true
then what would it equal sine theta
cosine 30 what is so Medical Center
that's a half of the hot which is what's
one but I'm pretty sure of sine 60 is
your one right so this is how the work
as long as equal to in fact equal to
what we just proved let me write
projector out of the way it is in fact
equal to sine alpha cons fear plus cos
alpha slowly bit up all you can
substitute for alpha sin being is
anything like Exorcist feeders a be
because that love your thing about an
identity you can put anything you like
in there is it works